weighing in at a colossal two and a half
tons Bentley's been Tyga out as all
previous SUVs and heads right to the
front of the pack no other SUV is as
heavy as fast or as expensive as the Ben
tiger for those who have everything but
want even more the basic version retails
for 200 thousand euros yet it's
completely sold out until the end of
next year it's said to be the most
sought after model of vw's British
subsidiary you mentioned sending that
Iggy most of our buyers are successful
businesspeople achievers in life who've
worked hard but we like to spoil
themselves and also like to show that
they've made it to the automobile top
half time on the automobile dish pizza
doesn't mention they're people who love
luxury and opulent trimmings who love
precision and skilled craftsmanship is
your nerdy Honda bite you know they're
people who buy Bentley's just mentioned
the Bentley Carlton the Infiniti q30 is
much smaller and less expensive the
Japanese mid-sized SUV is aimed
primarily at the European market
technologically that should be easy it's
smooth surface conceals a vast array of
German know how jointly produced with
Mercedes it's called the GLA in Japan
with development costs shared but
profits bought separately the segment
has been dominated by Volkswagens Teague
on for years slightly larger than its
predecessors the latest model now boasts
connectivity for the first time VW SUV
has the internet on board including
real-time navigation the tiguan is still
produced in vw's home planned involve
ugh but next year's stretched version
will be rolling off the company's
Mexican production line aimed at the US
market yes you via Cindy these are
important throughout the world people
love driving them in the US but they're
just as popular in China and in Europe
so the off-road craze continues unabated
a new Citroen prototype suggests
convertible versions could soon be
cruising roads as well as chlorine their
way over sand dunes